[Music]
on this Monday night reopening day in
some provinces which businesses are
getting back to some form of business
and the cautious optimism see what
happens and then do the next step
new alarm in the US and new defiance
this is my business and I have the right
to keep it open plus Italy loosens
europe's longest lockdown a dark time
for Canada's Airlines
hoping for a ticket out of turbulence
from taxpayers and how Kovac 19 is a
game-changer the sports world's goal for
a comeback
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
more Canadians are getting a sense of
the new normal as several provinces
begin to cautiously reopen parts of the
economy but as that happens Canada
reached another milestone the number of
confirmed cases of CO vid 19 in Canada
has now surpassed 60,000 more than 3,800
people are known to have died from it
here's how the numbers break down across
the country there are no new cases in
several provinces today New Brunswick
for example has had no new cases for 16
days it has had no deaths and has zero
active cases now and none of it
announced today it's only case was
actually a false positive in some places
the epidemic has been brought under good
control and the time is right for
cautious reopening other areas the
country may not be quite there yet but
we'll follow Quebec and Ontario are
still the worst there are 370 new cases
in Ontario today and the deaths of 84
more people Quebec recorded 758 new
cases today and 75 more deaths Quebec
Premier is now pushing back the date to
reopen non-essential businesses in the
Montreal area here's what you always
have to keep in mind the numbers we're
seeing now reflect what happened two
weeks ago that is the incubation period
and no one wants to see those numbers
start to rise again as Eric Sorenson
reports it's a delicate balance of
benefit versus risk in Quebec kovat 19
remains stubbornly active but businesses
like this bike shop were more than ready
to reopen you can see everybody that's
more like the smile and everybody's
happy and the long flu is really is
really it's really nice why shoot Quebec
is like many communities in the country
the virus outbreak was limited but the
economic impact was huge it was very
very painful financially because there's
no revenue the business is completely
closed Ontario remains cautious a few
businesses like car dealerships have
reopened and garden centers May is a
crucial sales period we hope to make it
through the year we think we'll make it
through the year because we're a grower
as well as a retailer Ontario says it
can open
further soon because it has finally
increased testing to more than 16,000
tests per day indeed expanding testing
is critical to containing and limiting
the spread of this new virus in Manitoba
malls have reopened groups up to 10 can
congregate restaurant patios are serving
they're emerging from lockdown with some
confidence in a province with very few
covert 19 cases it's wonderful a little
bit apprehensive because we've had no
customers for a month and a half now but
you know we've taken a lot of
precautions public health officials
across the country are cautiously
embracing the shift from lock down to
reopening so slowly carefully see what
happens and then do the next step I
think is a characteristic of all of the
plans back in Quebec the Montreal area
remains a hotspot business is scheduled
to open there next week will be delayed
now till May 18th I think it's extremely
important for these problems is to be
mindful of where they're at right now on
their epidemic curve and decide if it's
really appropriate for them to open up
or not one concern is the lag time in
detecting the spread of the virus the
economy may continue to reopen before we
learn whether it's spurring a new wave
of infections Erik Sorensen Global News
Toronto the Cargill meatpacking plant in
Alberta which had the biggest Cove in 19
outbreak in the country has reopened not
everyone's happy the union representing
workers held a rally outside the
facility in High River today it claims
not enough precautions are in place to
protect workers nearly half of the
plants 2,000 workers tested positive for
Kovach 19 one employee a 60 year old
woman died the plant closed two weeks
ago the Union argues it is still unsafe
the company says public health officials
will be on site to screen returning
employees two shifts are going ahead
with physical distancing in place
there's very very nominal work going on
inside the plant they essentially can't
operate as a packing house normally
would some workers are refusing their
right exercising their right to refuse
dangerous work the Cargill plant handles
more than one-third of Canada's beef
packing there are concerns about how a
longer shutdown would affect the supply
of meat in grocery stores and about the
financial impact on cattle ranchers
flying is a distant memory for most of
us now airlines are at a standstill
around the world the only thing that's
moving is their bottom line and it's
dropping fast even investor Warren
Buffett says he's dumping all his
holdings and airlines because the future
is so uncertain and today Air Canada
announced it lost 1 billion dollars in
the first quarter of 2020 the CEO says
the airline is effectively in
hibernation and plans to permanently
downsize its fleet and staff david aiken
is with me from ottawa david airlines
are looking for federal help are they
going to get it well Donna Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau was has today
about specific financial aid for
airlines like Air Canada and while he
did say the government is considering it
he was a bit vague on details and timing
we will be looking at sectoral supports
we will be making announcements on that
in the coming days or week the airlines
say they have specific needs there are
no tickets being sold or very little
tickets being sold and and carriers are
burning through money at an
unsustainable rate so some means of
providing a financial bridge for the
industry Canadian airlines are also
worried about help potential
international competitors are getting
from their governments
Air France on Monday got more than 8
billion dollars in loans and loan
guarantees from their government and
last month the US government agreed to a
25 billion dollar bailout for American
carriers in Canada help for Air Canada
WestJet Air Transat and others has
mostly been in the form of the emergency
wage subsidy program which airlines use
to bring back thousands of employees
that they had laid off but the airline's
say more help is needed
do you have seen countries all around
the world our g7 partners have all
announced measures to support their
their domestic aviation sector precisely
because they know the significance of
the sector and driving the economic
recovery Donna Air Canada's CEO had a
conference call with analysts this
morning he called this the darkest
period in civil aviation history
meanwhile Air Canada now has
some new safety measures for passengers
checking in at the airport there will be
mandatory temperature taking and that is
going to start by May the 15th and Air
Canada says it's the first airline in
North America to do that Donna okay
David akin in Ottawa thank you
all public health experts say we'll have
to get used to a new reality that our
lives will be disrupted unless and until
there is a vaccine for cope at 19 a huge
effort is underway at least 115 teams of
researchers in at least 21 countries are
working on a vaccine world leaders have
pledged almost eight billion dollars on
a global effort and today Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau said Canada would
contribute 850 million dollars to it
that includes money already allocated to
Canadian researchers working on
treatments and a vaccine even once we
find a vaccine whether it's in Canada or
elsewhere around the world we will share
that vaccine in its formula but
production of that vaccine will be
extremely important right around the
world as well it cannot just be the
wealthiest countries producing that
vaccine research is being fast-tracked
and several human clinical trials are
underway there's hope one could be
available within 12 to 18 months but
some researchers say that's too
ambitious for a vaccine that a more
reasonable time frame could be about
four years the u.s. is not taking part
in that global effort an internal US
government document projects there could
be a surge in deaths in the US by the
end of May as many as 3,000 deaths a day
and up to 200,000 new cases each day as
Jackson prosecco reports despite that a
number of American states are going
ahead and relaxing restrictions we're
joined now by President Donald Trump
facing the highest number of cases and
deaths in the world President Donald
Trump revised his projection for the
tolk ovid 19 will take on the US we're
gonna lose anywhere from seventy five
eighty to a hundred thousand people it's
a horrible thing we should lose one
person over this for weeks trump has
touted a figure of 60,000 deaths his
updated numbers may still be too low the
New York Times obtained a pessimistic
US government report it projects the
number of US deaths will climb from an
average of 1,700 per day to 3,000 per
day by June first the number of new
cases will rise from 25,000 per day to
200,000 per day we are not decreasing
out of this first wave so for me I worry
that we're not gonna really ever be out
of this first wave and that will
continue to go through a plateau with
some decreases here and there and some
spikes as New York and New Jersey see
improvement there are more new cases in
new places
Dallas reported its biggest single-day
jump two days after Texas began
reopening I have not seen a lot of use
of masks and there are certain areas in
certain times a day and certain places
where it doesn't seem like social
distancing is even an I think at least
35 states have loosened restrictions
despite none meeting White House
guidelines of two weeks of improvement
small reopening protests continue across
the country and there's open defiance of
stay-at-home orders this is my business
and I have the right to keep it open
with no domestic travel restrictions in
effect in the u.s. experts warn that as
cases grow in recently reopened states
they can easily spread seating the virus
at a time when the country still doesn't
have the capacity to fully test for it
Donna Jackson Prosecco in Washington
thanks in Italy people got their first
taste of life after lockdown in nearly
eight weeks going outside to exercise
and finally reuniting with family Italy
has had more than 200,000 confirmed
cases of Cova de 19 and at least 29,000
people have died from it though many
deaths may not have been recorded the
country's health care system was so
overwhelmed in early March the Prime
Minister ordered the entire country into
lockdown life has not returned to normal
but as crystal de man Singh reports
little changes are lifting spirits
[Music]
and embrace months in the making
Italian families are reuniting as the
country enters a new phase of living
with the pandemic but cannot I can't
even speak of how excited I am too
excited says this 72 year old
grandfather we've only seen her with
video calls for two months but it was
not the same families are allowed to see
one another again but they can't have
big gatherings and it's only family
friends will have to wait people can now
travel between communities and enjoy the
outdoors
Taylor lei is from British Columbia but
has been in the Lombardy region studying
she went out for a run for the first
time in 72 days I actually cried tears
of joy I was just so happy I love
running I don't care that there's a
mouth and it's just it really gives you
a lens of gratitude like you've never
had before in early March Italy became
the epicenter of the outbreak in Europe
to protect lives the economy was
sacrificed now about four million people
are back to work I hope people will have
common sense and understand that even if
they can't move around they still have
to be cautious at this one the reopening
is being staggered out of fear of a
second wave of infections schools
cinemas and most stores remain closed
life won't get back to normal anytime
soon but at least there's a little more
of joy crystal the Manson Global News
London
Carnival Cruise Line is planning to set
sail again in August the company says
it's phasing in some North American
service beginning August 1st eight ships
will leave ports in Florida and Texas
the change takes effect two weeks after
a no sale order expires in the United
States the Government of Canada though
is still advising travelers to avoid
cruise ships until further notice
progress in Fort McMurray coming up the
news
so people have been waiting for
there's relief in Fort McMurray tonight
all evacuation orders have been lifted
that means the 13,000 people forced from
their homes in the Rural Municipality of
Wood Buffalo can go back the ice jams on
two rivers have cleared a huge cleanup
is now underway and a boil water
advisory is in effect until September
Mayor Don Scott estimates the flooding
caused more than 100 million dollars in
damage it's now been four years since
the ferocious fire that forced more than
80,000 people to flee Fort McMurray that
fire burned more than 2,600 structures
most of them homes and today Natural
Resources Canada released its
projections for the upcoming forest fire
season in Alberta and across the country
by June conditions in western Canada
could explode to well above average risk
and Ontario and parts of Quebec are
predicted to have above-average forest
fire conditions things aren't expected
to cool off until September there's a
development in another killer disease
malaria it is spread by mosquito bites
and now scientists in the UK and Kenya
have discovered a microbe they say
protects mosquitoes from being infected
with malaria scientists discovered the
microbe inside the guts of mosquitoes on
Lake Victoria in Kenya they believe it
blocks the mosquitoes from carrying
malaria if they can't carry it people a
bite can't become infected they're
looking at weather releasing spores with
the microbe or male mosquitoes carrying
it into the wild will suppress the
disease more than 400,000 people are
killed by malaria each year most of them
children under the age of five ahead as
businesses edged closer to reopening how
opener Canadians to going back
we're all longing to get back to some
kind of normal but what that will look
like is still taking shape some kind of
physical distancing seems inevitable
Manitoba has gone farthest in loosening
restrictions including opening
restaurant patios today Mike Jarle gives
us a glimpse into the new reality at
restaurants like every other restaurant
Rudy's burgers in Toronto has had to
adapt no more inside seating leaving
customers to physically distance on the
street unlike so many struggling
restaurants the changes have worked at
Rudy's so well in fact that they don't
see themselves opening the doors until a
vaccine is available we're not
anticipating that there's gonna be
anybody coming into our restaurants
anytime soon the model that we have now
is for takeout and delivery and we see
this as the model for the short term
anyway recent polling by Ipsos found
that 71% of Canadians are staying away
from restaurants and coffee shops it's
it's staggering and terrifying number
four an industry that's built on people
being close to family and friends if
that essence is taken away from it will
the new reality look like this well we
are off the book bolster Darryl Bricker
has just released next a book of
forecasting future demographic trends in
Canada Society
will go back to normal he says but it
will take time how fast has less to do
with government rules as it does with us
the idea though that human beings are
somehow toxic and you have to be able to
manage your real your physical
relationship to them is a is a pretty
strong idea we'll have to see how
quickly people are able to get over that
in a restaurant that just reopened in
Bangkok a table of four now seats two
with a plastic divided down the middle
and everything the staff does is geared
towards physical distancing and safety
for some in Toronto blogger yashi Murphy
goes out at least twice a week with her
family at least they used to change she
says is inevitable but she believes
Canadians are resilient enough to change
as well so yes can I go out and eat with
my
I'd love to be able to do that it was a
big part of a life but if it just means
just the four of us going out then so be
it
I'll take whatever we can microlight
Global News Toronto next sports leagues
looking for a rebound
[Music]
[Applause]
these kids in Quebec offend a cool way
to pass the time they've perfected some
pretty impressive trick shots well
physically distancing from carefully
crafted tennis moves from the top of
roofs to shooting hoops standing on
tires well a lack of sports is one of
the side effects of this virus not only
can you not play team sports there's
nothing to watch either professional
leagues are working on plans to bring
back sports in some form or another but
as Mike Armstrong reports don't get your
hopes up if you needed a sports fix like
we're pretty desperate maybe this is it
Florida Casino is once again running
high light games but with some kovat 19
considerations they aren't playing
doubles so there's less contact on the
court there are no locker rooms players
sit where they're normally be fans and
that no point is a bare hand allowed to
touch the ball when the ball comes off
the court it's going to be sanitized in
a soapy solution with bleach in it and
it's not gonna be touched for two days
after that those are some of the
complications major league sports are
dealing with as well in baseball can
players be sent back into crowded
dugouts there's even talk of computers
calling balls and strikes so there isn't
an umpire breathing down the back of the
catcher one plan being considered is to
have teams pick up a shortened season
and a few selected cities but they'd
have to test players for kovat 19 weekly
hopefully we get to a point where that's
possible now there's another question
about tests if governments are still
struggling to test the public how would
it look for say the NBA to start a
massive testing program with the brand
take a hit but even if there were enough
test kits in a month or two and the NHL
tried to pick up again travel might
still be an issue
anybody who arrives here from another
country will have to follow all
quarantine rules the NHL is considering
isolating players and staff in a small
number of cities and holding tournaments
that would likely be without fans but
even if the league was able to reopen
this fall or winter fans could be
rolling
to return and the stadium experience
could be different going forward not
unlike air travel where you know they're
saying they might have to be some sort
of when it resumes a different
configuration of seats there may also be
setbacks as one European soccer league
is finding out this week the Bundesliga
has been blanket testing hoping to
resume play it announced Monday it's
found ten players tested positive and
may have to postpone its plans Mike
Armstrong global news and that is global
national for this Monday I'm donor
Friesen we lead you tonight with a
special tribute from some professional
athletes players from 14 leagues
including Canada's Haley Wiccan Heiser
and Bianca and rescue are honoring
frontline workers with the hashtag the
real heroes are covering their jerseys
with the name of a health worker they
want to personally say thank you to
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves
bye bye
[Music]